my name is amy starr cesky and i'm the
associate director of the oral history
master's program here at Columbia this
is part of our year-long lecture series
where we present work that's exciting to
us in the field of oral history we're
just so proud to have Lillian here to
talk with us to make so I wanted to say
that this event was generously
co-sponsored by the center of oral
history by insight and by the Center for
the Study of race and ethnicity who
especially donated a beautiful flyer for
the event that we're all realized about
with and and so I'm going to turn it
over to me Marshall Clark he's going to
introduce Lillian and then look at the
seal a little bit of the film in here
money and i'm the director of the center
for world history at Columbia and I am
honored to be able to make this
presentation in honor of the Polish
valve lecture series because when i
think of paul lazarsfeld all that he did
to help us a coin the term mass media
fleeing Nazi austria i came to the
united states and began to talk about
the media and all of his complications
in the mass culture and whether or not
we could get real information and how
was information being commodified and
capitalism and on so forth I don't know
anybody more suited to speak in honor of
fog letters from than Lillian Jimenez I
first met Lillian many many years ago
when we were both young we were
consulting for the Rockefeller
Foundation and two in the arts in your
arts program and I was there because
they have a lot of oral history
applications and I didn't know how to
behave in a place is fancy the
Rockefeller Foundation and I've just
barely didn't say anything and Lillian
sir took me under her wing and we were
sent to Sitka Alaska together to do a
consultation with the young woman it was
struggling to understand the claimant
the Klingon it's in Sitka I remember of
Lillian's character so well because this
woman have a lot of problems with their
research and i would probably said in
her approach to
people I probably said you know she's
not prepared to do this let's just write
on her poor saying we can't suggest
funding and we and Lily said no this
teacher and we took her and lily I
listen to lily and talk to her for four
hours and be very honest with her and
tell her exactly what her problems were
and she cried she we gave her cookies
Lily give her some companies as a
product and if she rewrote that proposal
and it was such in three weeks and it
was such a beautiful basil it just
showed me the Lillian is as an educator
as a social reformer and as a person to
help us understand race and ethnicity in
the world today and so Lillian has has
conducted media literacy workshops and
Latino stereotypes self-representation
color raise power social relations and
the construction of whiteness she worked
five years with the Center for Porto
Rican studies at Hunter College on a
series of world history is in a sense
those oral histories done there among
the best really in the city that
chronicled the Puerto Rican communities
institution building in New York she did
a beautiful documentary you will see he
will talk about maybe see portions out
tonight on the Antonio kintel huh and i
would like to honor Antonio's partner
Mina
the audience thing that can just show
who you learn and I was actually their
tummy spirit to our place and and I just
said lily and he's now working on a new
documentary about the Puerto Rican left
in New York City you know I always
acknowledge Nina dr. bump dough has
partner and and we've become friends
after dr. Pantoja past Nina was the
extraordinary partner and I want to say
that you know you see these great loves
my aunt and my uncle had this great loan
you know sort of like oh my god they
loved each other so much so you talk
about these great loves you know Tony
and Nina were like the second great love
that i was privileged and honored to
really be a witness to it was an
extraordinary relationship so I'm always
happy to have me none here and if people
want to ask me two questions you know
I'm happy to share with her she knows
more about Tony and I do I wanted to
just do a very very short introduction
if that's okay and then I'm going to
show you a little bit of the other
documentary about 13 minutes of the
portion on hospita and the portion on
the consent decree I interviewed Tony
well I met Tony in 1998 when she was
considering moving back to New York from
Puerto Rico and she wanted to write her
memoirs and the first thing she said she
asked me is where's the history where's
the history of Puerto Ricans in New York
and I was like kidding there's not very
much written about us it's just the
stereotype so you're gonna have a hard
time finding she said no no I'm
good research and so as Mina we're gonna
find the research we're gonna go to all
the libraries and she did a couple
months later she calls me up and she
says oh my god you were right there's
very little there's garbage out there I
can't believe it we have to do this
project I have to write my memoirs left
to make a film we have to do this have
to do that and then you know Tony really
got very carried away and wanted to do
this massive media project to right all
the wrongs and unfortunately we didn't
quite get there to do that but tony was
a visionary she was a visionary an
extraordinary planner and a person who
would look at you she was born in super
home and I think that's probably why she
had this disability to see who you could
be as opposed to who you were in a
moment so being born in so wrong so
wrong is an old password and basically
it means that in the South they said
you're born with a caul over your face
it's really that the amniotic sac is
intact and so the Midwife had to break
it open and her parents and her
grandmother and people in her family
used to say there's a child with a
special destiny because she survived
coming out of that amniotic sac alive
and when she would do is that she would
look at these young people because young
people were her focus and she would look
at them and not see who they are in the
moment she would see the lawyer she
would see the doctor she would see the
philosopher she would see the planner
she would see all these patch tributes
all these qualities in them and she
would say to them I can you gonna be a
doctor and they were saying what I'm
ready a doctor and she was I can see
that you wouldn't be a doctor I've heard
you in the meetings and you talk about
biology and you talk about science and
and then all of a sudden his child would
say I'm gonna be a doctor so she
inspired people she helped them to
realize their potential that's what I
think made her for me anyway so
incredibly extraordinary I was speaking
with a class earlier and some of you may
or may not
oh this but Puerto Ricans are in many
ways immigrants because we come with a
different culture in a different
language but we are united states
citizens and that makes us migrants 1917
we were made citizens of the United
States just a few months before World
War one what a happy coincidence so that
we could go to world war one and fight
on behalf of the United States and the
United States has shaped the economy of
quarter rico in very dramatic ways and
what we had in the 50s late 40s 50s and
60s we had many of the folks in the
agricultural countryside moving into the
cities in Puerto Rico and from the
cities then having to move to New York
in many cases they were recruited
through a bracero program to come and
work on the northeast of the United
States as well as in Hawaii so there are
Puerto Ricans in Hawaii who are so
freaking and actually this little boy
I'm sorry I got that from Tony he's not
a little boy he's a young man Bruno Mars
it's half Puerto Rican and half Hawaiian
and so you know this is part of that
whole Exodus out of Puerto Rico so this
bracero program really brought people to
the United States at the same time that
these programs from the Department of
Labor are bringing Puerto Ricans to the
United States there is this interesting
phenomenon that's happening after World
War 2 which is that the government and
the social agencies are trying to get
women back into the home from the
workplaces so during World War Two you
remember all these women went into the
workforce and now they have to get the
bad because the men returned
and they wanted their jobs back so the
women had to go back in so they had this
huge campaign about the stability of the
family and the way in which it started
to manifest itself was an emphasis on
juvenile delinquency so here come the
Puerto Ricans the others the immigrants
the ones that can't speak English who
are an exceptionally young population so
guess who becomes the poster children
for to bunnell delinquency the Puerto
Ricans and so feature films were made in
the late 50s in the early 60s that
really inscribed our stereotyped as
criminals as oversexed as unstable as
for the women fecund and promiscuous and
easily available and these stereotypes
have continued in great measure to this
day extending themselves not just to
Puerto Ricans but to other Latino groups
and have come to the United States so if
your Latin you're the Latin bombshell
and you know there are obviously
stereotypes of other people I say this
because I think it's really important
the way in which the mass media really
characterizes and depicts certain groups
and then those groups have quite a
struggle to be able to break down those
stereotypes and to create images of
themselves that are really refuting
those stereotypes so it's not that we
didn't have promiscuous women of course
we did because that's reality right that
everybody was promiscuous no so I want
to just name a few of those wonderful
films cried off 1959 where john saxon
plays a Puerto Rican do you remember
John Saxon was not born
rico i want to talk about the blackboard
jungle where a mexican plata porto rican
who is a pathological liar and stutters
and the only time he stopped stuttering
is when he has a knife in his hand a
phallic symbol so again rien scribing
our sexuality and I want to talk about
West Side Story I used it fair use fair
use in the film and so bear that in mind
when you make your documentary there's
such a thing as fair use and the other
film I want to advise young savages so
in West Side Story we become the
juvenile delinquents we're the gangsters
and again this issue of our sexuality is
inscribed in the American consciousness
it gets worse with the young savages
which was a really interesting film
because it is what is called a social
problem film it's problematizing
assimilation in the United States in New
York in particular it's problematizing a
lot of the social theories that the
sociologists were raising about juvenile
delinquents but the Puerto Ricans are
really the pathological ones and so in
that story just to give you a sense of
how bad it was there's a blind warlord
who is killed he's a Puerto Rican
warlord and he's killed and the reason
why he's killed is because unbeknownst
to the audience he's the warlord but
he's also the pimp of his young sister
and the mother knows that the brother is
pimping out the daughter and so telly
savalas is in it this other guy
Lancaster is in it print dina merrill
there's all these interesting stars and
we're inscribed as these juvenile
delinquents of an extraordinary nature
so i say that because much of our
history is a hidden history but the
stereotypes prevail you know to the
extent that people still site mainstream
media as a way to begin to define and
determine who we are historically the
other thing I want to say is that
many of the young people who came to New
York spoke Spanish and they were
children and you'll hear a one-person
story children who did not speak English
the immersion theory was the way in
which children were assimilated into the
educational process so sink or swim you
didn't speak English tough you were
going to learn it you know my hook or by
crook a lot of children were placed in
because they couldn't speak English they
were placed in classes for crd i just
had a brain seizure classes for retarded
mental development and so I had a cousin
was placed in one of those classes and
never recovered from being identified as
being retarded I think it was like a
self-fulfilling prophecy she's just been
you know escaped from the world so
thousands of children were placed in
there because we had about an
eighty-five percent drop out rent and
again because children didn't understand
what was going on they were just
dropping out including an elementary
school which you know to this day and
age you wouldn't believe I want to say
that there were social networks but it
really will in that time period the
Puerto Rican community but the
overwhelming group of people who really
made a mark were Tony and her cohorts
and that's not to say that there were
not others that came there were labor
organizers there were community
organizers there were people from all
over just me but I believe that Tony's
homework was really looking at having
impact across the city whereas the
organizers from the earlier period we're
really looking at specific areas Tony's
position was are going to work with high
school students because in four years
are going to be in college and then four
years after that they're going to be the
leaders of our community and so that was
her vision that was what she wanted to
create and she really did say we can do
this for ourselves she was one of the
first people to take the anti-poverty
money and start to create puerto rican
organizations in the community she was a
founder of the puerto rican forum which
engendered a speedo
she was a founder of diversity that
boricua which engendered boricua college
which exists today so she was just a
founder of organizations she just kept
doing this all over the country you
won't see this part in the film but she
went to San Diego where she met Mina and
she started with Mina school a graduate
school for community organizing so she
was always learning and always changing
and really in tune with whoever it was
that she worked with the last thing I'll
say is that and i'll talk about it later
on but i was i I did 17 hours of oral
history with Tony before she passed and
this film was built around those 17
hours of oral history and you know I
finally figured out what the narrative
was what the story what's the story I
want to tell and then I took from the
oral histories in order to tell that
story and then outside of oral histories
interviewed a lot of her cohorts in
order to fill out give texture to the
story of her life and work so if i'm
going to say i'ma show you about 13
minutes of the film and then we can have
a conversation if you like
I have reached and you'll organize blue
in people in which you would be like a
game at all would be like again kind of
planning and that's what has to be a
music legend and you have to given the
things that the gang will bring
identification with a jacket we symbol
with ceremony capito is probably the
first point in own and control
organization the Chinese are these
things they created a spirit clubs in
high schools and they had a centralized
time and that developed a curriculum
from working with the youth in the high
schools but also they would have
workshops at the SP our offices
everything we will do with we decided we
would not have counselors will have
organized a cancerous without in the
concept they have to have a personality
when an organizer and at the same time
tying themselves in being dumb super
same patient of cancer so I comes loose
in the high schools
the name Espina a one word of meat that
incorporates in the whole sensor we were
talking us a crane espera espera a
command to the kids that age is the one
point where you can interfere and come
in and break the cycle thority on break
in and bringing knowledge where the
young can change the world I parents are
very proud the fact that I was work from
our student when my father read the
article una tienda de prensa and he
spoke to my mother and then he called me
always to be enough of a virus it's an
organization that helps high school
students in wanna go to college yes I to
party become a layup and see if you know
they can help us at a time he's a
collector of us era was dr. Lillian
October and so she was the person who
met with us she turned to me and she
said we're organizing a spinner clothes
and then you can work and I for 12 in
her school we organized it we call the
department campuses here girl when you
grew up in a neighborhood which you
venture very little water Thank You
homework I came from what you might call
the wrong side of the track this
organization in a speeder import p.m. oh
that of the world my world was the
lonely side
and all the sudden New York City came
into focus for me so I speed I really
opens up new horizons for all of us not
my father asking me about the cost of
college tell him about Rita probably
cost eighteen thousand dollars and then
serum even know how much that is the
mortgage I make it was to us being under
began to realize and I likely to attend
college and with their help I've learned
about financial aid and scholarships and
applied to different schools none of
those was a lot of girls were noticed
foot but it had like the talks
presentation about the history of Puerto
Rico about the culture but we also learn
social skills to this whole process of
interacting we used to have lots of ice
and a balloon
but I do recall when I was a student in
a speeder some of the controversy that
surrounded us PETA for you know for many
years the board of education was number
one obstacle they said we don't accept
those councils you have because they
don't have a license and we should talk
we don't counseling new facilities we
cancel ill second objection so you want
to segregate where the chickens on the
record is a hallmark card when you
segregate them it's okay when we do it
and this is not segregated this is
organizing for our own strength and to
have them finish school and not drop out
as to get letters abusive and you know
with all kinds of horrible language in
them calling me all kinds of names and
growing lost all kinds of things taking
our money here no your low back to where
you belong those members of our
community including for period of time
in the 60s the more radical elements in
our community who said as era was you
know just creamy and it was just focused
on the cream of the crop of the Puerto
Rican community and I was not the cream
of the crop in terms I lived in the
projects and my parents were working
class so I always used to say what what
is this you know what we're knocking
here if it's bringing people who are
developing a consciousness into
trillions in the needs of our community
what's wrong about that
going to our culture and is okay they
are 80 e the tiny no unions used to
celebrate an areito where you plan
something and Italians anyway became a
beautiful a sense of an important moment
the Rho is held in a dark room turn off
the lights and everybody has a little
tangled and you get light from the
center and we all be sworn in as a las
bolante or walking in what I candles Oh
nicely dressed and in a in make me frown
or being in a poor wicked it was
in 63 we would discuss in our plug a
tease you know what was happening with
the civil rights movement and how the
situation of Puerto Ricans was so
similar to what was happening to
african-americans at that time so it was
like a way of seeing my god you know
we're not speak about the city we are
you know we could really do this it
empowered us to feel that we had the
capacity to gain new skills and the
capacity to transform society they bloom
and they they flower and they became
this is fighters
someone who gave me on Laura's somewhere
became the school production of the 60s
some of those people who got there is no
match by the police closed in city
college
because we came to my speed and we were
already planted we were already
organized it we had organized a little
high schools already those that will
graduate nice we weren't getting into
the city colleges so we call for boycott
at 7am I was in my Volkswagen Beetle Bug
came right on the campus cop study cast
a stepbrother it's time to get up you
close him down to school this is now
Harlan University
we have received the campus after a
series of assaults and fights as college
open this morning and they gotta know
the bureau gada we are talking about it
by the neck and closed his office and
stood in on his desk and told him you
know you know gonna get out near until
recently demands one of the things that
we want to see was City College reflect
the diversity of the graduating classes
of the city's high schools number to a
second back and working in smaller
studies wasn't booming and took over the
campus this was a major of vacant my
phone starts ringing left over
because by French style it's a speed on
this inside today look at the City
College of NATO open its like seven
percent minority which is major
accomplishment all King thirty-three
percent
we started to learn from the youth what
was happening to them in the schools
when I first went to kindergarten I was
slapped by the teacher for speaking in
Spanish and I went home and told my
mother and my mother did not know how to
speak English but she went over there
and she gave them a piece of her mind
mrs. Lewis is that
we'll take you to jail if you don't take
your children to school let's turn in
your arm okay if let's say well it says
that I'm have to take my children to
school then I can accuse you as an
institution where I have earned my
children and you don't teach them now
those days we didn't talk a lot about
special education and you heard about
open-air classes you're about special
health classes and so on but ornery
genius is often or put into those
classes you know and no problem to the
health or anything like that but the
school said you didn't know what to do
one we have an ad hoc worsen dropout
rate word if the kid doesn't wanna be
seen by the teacher and the her eldest
and was going on they don't speak
english and the classes i think you know
what you're doing your job on the mound
there are no funds in this budget for a
number of programs such as producing and
purchasing special instructional
materials to help the teachers and the
disadvantaged areas of the city there
are no funds to help increase the number
of Negro ordering can teachers in our
system nor any incentive fund to
encourage new ideas that he tried out in
the district i became like that highline
the discussion was beginning with in a
speeder and other community groups that
it might require litigation to obtain
some goals that we were striving for
this was a lawsuit of major importance
to the Puerto Rican community and this
was in the time of our civil rights in
green all kinds of actions on the basis
of fact they were being denied to
process movie ended on an equal
opportunity
there was consent decree that said that
the Board of Education in New York City
had to teach the children in the
language of their culture and his
English in an effective way there's no
question mark it had not been to consent
decree we would not have done Latino
teachers into the school system at that
point the war when you is is a big
monster to fight and I a monster
I wanted to say something about what
happened to Puerto Ricans when we
arrived in the United States when we
arrived in the United States the United
States was really looking at race in a
binary fashion where I the right for you
were black and puerto ricans where I
continue to be a mixed-race people and
so we did not identify as either some
people identified is white because you
know clearly there's racism in Puerto
Rico so we can't deny that which is
really tied with class in a way that's
not quite the same reality in the United
States and so when we came here there
was this push-pull about who we
identified with and I think it's really
important to note that Tony's position
was that we were not going to assimilate
into this quote-unquote melting pot
because she felt like the melting pot
really was acceptance of the dominant
norm the dominant society and so you if
you decided you were going to assimilate
you had to give up everything to become
somebody else and her cohort and earlier
cohorts for her cohort in particular
institutionalized this notion of not
assimilating and they were one of the
first groups to really look at the
hyphen she started by saying we are
Puerto Rican New Yorkers and then she
moved to we are Puerto Rican Americans
but she never said we're Americans she
always said with Puerto Rican and
something else you know we belong to
this country with a band is going to go
to stay in this country but we're not
giving up our language and we're not
giving up our culture and that was
something that I think was really
important because it's not something
that's been recognized that that's a
contribution that Puerto Ricans made so
the bilingual struggle the struggle for
bilingual education was really extremely
significant and I didn't know how
significant it was until Tony actually
organized the conference at the cuny
graduate center contra Molly Maria and
there were a group of students from cuny
there and this polish boy was there with
his class and he got out but he said
because they were talking about the
consent decree he said I didn't know
that I was in a bilingual class because
Porto Ricans fought for bilingual
education and everybody in the room just
like turn around and looked at him and
thought oh my god we never thought about
other groups other than puerto ricans
benefiting from bilingual education but
that's the reality of you know the
struggle in Puerto Ricans took on and
actually won I say one with a caveat
that bilingual education was not funded
the way that it needed to be because the
city was in a financial crisis a fiscal
crisis in the 70s when the consent
decree came in and so there was no
standardization of what bilingual
education was and it was dismantled I
mean really just piece by piece it was
dismantled over the years um so you'll
have dual language schools but I did
want to mention that about raising color
because I think it's really important
the issue of race and color in the
Puerto Rican community when Tony was a
young woman i am sure i don't know this
for a fact although we did have a lot of
conversations about raising color I
don't know this for a fact but i do
believe because she was socialized in a
country that really pushed towards the
european and whiteness you know we have
all these ways of talking about fully
still do all these ways of talking about
color and raised in puerto rico so i
believe that Tony really
to do a personal journey of beginning to
discover herself as a black Puerto Rican
that she did not identify as a photo
Rican when she was a young woman but by
the time of her passing she absolutely
and totally identified as a black Puerto
Rican her family was a black Puerto
Rican Family she was the most light skin
of her family so I felt like that was
really important to throw in there
because it's not something you think
about race or color you don't think
about Puerto Ricans but I think as
hybridity becomes more than norm and you
think about the fact that there's so
many different mixtures of people we
were one of the early hybrids so I don't
even just say that um I guess I'll open
it up to questions kick to heaven it's
an oral history questions he said that
on you if you did 17 hours of
interviewing I'm wondering how an assume
that I'm tell you it was a really
amazing narrator how did how did your
interviews change over time so um you
know I am I asked her to sort of do the
trajectory of her life and tell me about
what she had done I looked at a lot of
the some videotapes people had done
interviews with her so I looked at some
of those videotapes I think the
questions got a little deeper I think
they got a little more probing i forgot
to the end there's a section you haven't
seen in the film which wasn't part of
the oral history that you know in the
oral history she was telling me her life
story so it was nice and wonderful and
seamless in some ways but she was a
human being
all kinds of flaws and really
interesting traits and I asked her if
she was ever afraid because I felt like
people were going to want to know that
and she really didn't want to talk about
these really sort of inches a really
private person she didn't but you know I
really went after her and I kept that
and I could say how are people going to
know he was a human being if you don't
open up so in the oral history it really
was about what she did the film part was
really cool are you so I would say that
that's what I learned I learned that I
had to move away from what's your story
because she's so private too who are you
and you know we did a lot of interviews
with her in Puerto Rico actually where
she was skating and you know dodging and
she was greated and you know eventually
I got these little kernels out of her
but it was really much more for the
documentary but her story was her story
you know which is pretty fascinating
actually
to see so how long did the project take
and from the organic till the end and
how has your thinking and understanding
of who she is in a row change during
that time and like in the gap from them
to now Wow well you know no film can
capture all the aspects of the person or
all of you know what they experienced I
was at her commitment say I was with her
when she passed so you know my
understanding of her now house so much
more cheaper yeah yeah I'm hoping
somebody else will make another film
about her that will capture some of the
things that I didn't catch it um I think
that she was um she became a really high
side so the film started somewhere like
around two thousand and one we start to
raise money for it but I wasn't really
in filmmaking mode she passed in 2002
and I thought oh my god now I'm gonna
make a film like you know she's gone and
I don't have any footage of her because
I wasn't thinking about the oral
histories footage for a documentary it
was a oral history and you know then I
sort of floundered around for a while
and was trying to make the migration
film and then he was showing that around
and people were like where's Tony
where's tell me she sort of lost in this
and then had a crisis worked on another
film and then came back and said okay so
now i think it's going to be about Tony
and it's about her life and then I said
I'm going to use the normal histories
and this is how I'm gonna frame it and I
got up to this point as I mentioned
earlier you know I thought her work in
New York was most important but if Toews
going to really show the full dimension
of who she was and how she had grown
then I had to look at the work that she
did in San Diego and I had to look at
the work that she did in Puerto Rico and
I had to look at some of her
deliberations so she wanted to move to
Nicaragua so part of the film talks
about her
going to a conference in Nicaragua being
totally taken by the Nicaraguan
revolution and she was going to go and
you know be with the Nicaraguan
revolutionaries and then she calls me
now she says I think I'm going to go to
Nicaragua and Mina said what I said now
you have unfinished business he did you
have unfinished business in Puerto Rico
she said oh that's right I've done all
these things all over the country I have
to go to Puerto Rico I have unfinished
business in Puerto Rico in Mena and Tony
moves to Puerto Rico so the work that
she did in Puerto Rico was you know just
like the extension of what she had done
in New York what she'd done in San Diego
by the time she'd gone to San Diego she
had become a Marxist she knew about
political economy she had really
embraced art a central to Community
Development she didn't think solely in
political and economic terms now she
thought in terms of art and the way in
which art makes community come alive and
it became a central component of her
organizing for the school so she had a
theatre group that she in q baited at
the school she had three galleries I
mean she used to do activities in the
community you know Harold he's goofy
pictures of her on this stitch you she
was very tiny with a huge afro and I
know these pictures of her on the stage
where these you know aztec dancers in
the background or dancing and you know
she was almost a dwarfed by them so I
didn't use it but really it was her the
way in which she just kept developing as
a person and then at the end I think you
know she's I don't know I don't want to
get emotional I don't know how to do
this and I could say we hang on to watch
sound I heard up and I said well I think
you do it the way you live your life and
that's exactly what she didn't she
brought everybody was close to her she's
incredibly collaborative and what she
did she was the boss but she was really
collaborative she always asked a
pinochle what do you think what do you
think I should do what do you think we
should do and at the end that's what she
did she brought everybody together and
said we need the gushy dinner and we
said this is what we think you should do
it she said okay this is what I'm not
and then she did it um so she by the end
of this film I mean she just became this
extraordinarily deep and you know rich
in complicated complicated person you
know she was really insecure like I owe
all of us right that's what human beings
are she was really insecure she never
manifested that insecurity except you
know people she was close to and I
wanted to capture some of that I the
other thing I'll say is I'm wanted
people to say bad things about her I
don't mean it doesn't like when I say
this but it's true I wanted people to be
antagonistic to say no I don't think she
did this or I disagree with her and we
had a fight by the time I got to the
film you know when people die they
become Saints and then you know you
can't say anything bad about them I
don't know if another cultures that's
the reality but for Puerto Ricans you
can't say anything bad about somebody so
all these people who want you hating her
Oh God say anything ungrounded and one
person who I who said will you say it's
something notified they had a fight they
had political struggle and she bested
her in this political struggle I mean
that's my interpretation of right she
wouldn't say that she would say I walked
away but I think we won the struggle to
me um and I said to him so blue you say
this on camera that you had this
political difference it was about
political ideologies struggle around
politics and he said yeah and then when
I went to ask him he said I couldn't say
that about her
you know why so much she stands I can't
say so you're not going to see any of
that you know for drama you need
conflict you need tension and there
Sonny was drama tension in her life me
you know a lot of people who did not
like her um so yeah she became a really
quite richer person to me he said that
she was a really private person how did
you negotiate that when you're making
the film after she had passed and you
couldn't sort of check in with her about
what was okay and not okay to put into
it so tell him a story about how I how I
outed her or help me now did her so you
know I'm it said to her we went to see
Jenny parameter not many people know
chatty Mona and her work so Jenny when I
did the spectacular when she's a
powerhouse and I said that scope that I
had met her once at a conference I
fallen in love with her other conference
looks like one she's cool um so she was
going to reset she was gonna you know do
a presentation at the cuny graduate
center so mean and and Tony and I went
and she was like all right I introduced
man and she she's wonderful she's great
and she said you know baba Baba I know
right and we were in the car I'm driving
I'm like we crazy you're not out so
we're having this conversation with her
as I'm driving she's like antimatter man
i'ma tell you what you're not Tony I
might have to deal with this in the film
she said you do what you have to do in
this film it's your film I'm not I tell
you how to do your film you you make
your own film you'll make your film so
I'm like okay and I'm dancing around the
fact that she's a lesbian I'm dancing
around and dancing crown so I put a
little thing in momina Cesaro me and
Tony man and whatever and I go to a
speed up to see these little kids who
look like my grandchildren I swear to
God and they're mixed you know such as
Puerto Ricans from all over the place
including african-american Arab Asian I
me was just extraordinary so these
little children I mean that's how I
thought of them right these little
children I show them that the what was
then the rough cut where I'm dancing
around her being
lesbian and these kids start to ask
questions so I'm like yeah sure what is
it did she get married no was that her
daughter in the film know what she a
lesbian I'm like I'm like yes I'm this
little girl I'll never forget this
moment I always say this this little
tiny girl gets up and she puts her hand
on her hip and she says do I not seem
fair and I'm like what she said you're
not being fair you have to say who she
is oh and I must have like taking a few
steps back and thought oh my god she
just pumped me out oh my god and you
know I had a lot of struggle around this
my sound person I said to him I'm going
to see Julio when I asked these
questions about Tony being gay about the
gay community and the contributions they
made to the Puerto Rican community and I
want him to talk about her being gay and
he said what are you crazy you're gonna
ruin her legacy and I was like what now
he adored her he adored her and he said
that to me and I thought my god my life
see so when that little girl said that
to me and a couple of other kids were
like yeah yeah yeah absolutely they all
were like yeah you should do this if I
went into the editing room and I said
I'm going to bite the bullet and I don't
give a what happens whatever comes
comes I'm going to do it because if
those children are brave enough you know
what I mean to put it out there then I'm
going to put it out there and I have to
tell you that in screenings people have
said to me why did you deal with her
sexuality it has nothing to do with who
she is are you kidding me that's exactly
who she is that's why I had up with it I
couldn't do a film around her petticoat
up right until the kids out of me
her if I didn't talk about who she was
and she was a lesbian that was like so
profoundly deep inside of her she acted
out of that and everything that she did
how could I not do that never I we don't
think that's important and I said well
it's okay but you know it was very scary
for me because I did get a lot of flack
from people who said oh she's the first
recipient of the middle of you know
freedom of first Puerto Rican woman 1996
President Clinton yada yada and I was
like that's right and the way that I cut
it was that after she gets that metal
you hear she's a mess that's the way I
cut it because I said oh yeah not you
not want to put it in your face because
he honored her she was honored so um it
was a journey for me as well you know so
you know I was a good Ally but I was
really afraid of doing her legacy and
those kids that do it and I said you
know what when the kids tell you to do
something when the children speak you
gotta listen because they're they're
fearless they're fearless so you have to
be fearless like them I'm curious about
if Tony's spoke to her experience of her
gender and being a partisan movement I
I've heard heard you talk about that how
race was talked about and perceived and
how and in the film the civil rights
movement I'm kind of providing that
feedback and involvement and that's sort
of a setting but there was also the
woman's move
and and so I'm a bit right and so I my
experience of movements and movement
building is that gender is very
contentious and that that within
movement communities women tend to be
sidelined so I was wondering if Tony
spoke to that or just her experience of
being a woman oh absolutely I mean she
really did it and she was very clear
that women I mean you must remember she
was operating in the 50s in New York and
the Puerto Rican community was ruled by
men now okay so here here's what Tony
here's Tony's theory on it when the
small community based organization
started to emerge it was women they were
built on the backs of women in the
community now when the money started to
come in then the men started to take
over and she only said the women were
taken out of their leadership roles and
the men stepped in when the money came
in and so all these women who had helped
build all these organizations Joseph
vienna's go Donna Sanchez and all these
people had been in her cohorts they were
pushed aside and then the man the
curious and the careerist men so as many
were really buying the capitalist model
of achievement they came in and they
took over all these organizations and
she was really clear I mean towards the
end of her life she didn't care she was
just like she'd get off then she tell
everybody the men took over and you did
because the money came and blah blah
blah blah blah so she was pretty clear
about the role of gender and the way in
which women had been shunted aside is
that not accurate Mina when we did our
part program sponsored some of the first
female
comic but once I comedians but comedians
and one of those is Kathy Najimy Kathy
Najimy you remember Kathy from sister al
was she started with performance via
theatre group and she would project
images of oppression against women
images of the contradiction that women
had to face in their lives and we at the
graduates in that our multicultural art
institute was the only home base that
would receive her and give her license
to work she did not identify the
feminist movement because as you know
now many of us women color believe that
we have been excluded from the
definition of that book i went to a
woman's conference in Minnesota when his
history conference in Minnesota and I
showed the family mine you know it
wasn't yet finished so you know didn't
have the soundtrack I had other music a
little goofier and I was like oh okay so
you know if they get a little round of
applause it'll be fine yeah be cool I'll
walk away happy and the film finished
and all these women I have to tell you
these women who was like international
students came up to me crying and I was
like what's going on either so I had
this German woman come up to me she was
sobbing and I was like why is she crying
what's wrong she said she inspired I
said she'd inspired me i'm gonna do
something I was like oh my god and then
this Cuban woman said I don't know what
radiance and she was like so emotional
so all these women from like other
places mostly German right to tell you
this was bothering me all these German
when we came up that day and said but
i'd say in general the response has been
really very positive she's a compelling
character so you may take exception with
the structure you may take exception
with something but i mean i think
I captured her spirit that's what I did
I captured her spirit who she was not
everything about her but her spirit and
you know the people that knew her
intimately I really waited for them to
tell me what are you thinking they would
say oh my god can't even you can't you
her spirit and for me that was like one
of the most important things to do now I
want to talk to some of the technical
stuff all right so we've got all our
history stuff out of the way I felt that
there was no um no eight millimeter
super 8 footage of Puerto Ricans right
rodriguez told me because i could say i
want to use super 8 I want to use 8
millimeter you know when I was growing
up we had eight millimeter in our family
and people took pictures of us they're
lost now I'm sure case for most folks so
I put a call out low in the hole who
should show up this a speed on and
Nintendo sado all the super 8 footage in
there is hers and they are a speed on
please all of those kids were a speed of
students so I will stun that I actually
got super 8 footage of us being a
student so those kids were dancing all
goofy stuff that's about the SP on this
you know I can name some of them now
because I've met them during the course
of the interview that I did so that was
the first thing second thing when I
looked for footage of Puerto Ricans
right cuz you need Bureau especially
when you know Latino Public Broadcasting
told me to take Tony out of the film you
noticed a film about her because you
know she wasn't shot well I had to look
for a lot of archival footage you know
to represent that time period and I
thought okay so I'll find some footage
somewhere and I have to tell you I have
to scour every single television station
in new york and beyond for footage that
wasn't about crime criminals prison
junkies delinquents and so i did find
some footage i found a short film that
was made by NBC on the bilingual
education program and so that's actually
a bilingual school the first bilingual
school in the Bronx
and one of the women in it is an early
educator who's like the mother of all
the Puerto Rican educators in the United
States and when I showed it to her she
was going to pass out and die so I found
footage all kinds of people people
didn't know that they have been
videotaped so I found them in ear you um
it's extremely expensive to purchase
archival footage so it can be over one
hundred and twenty dollars the second
I'm not joking is not a minute a second
$90 a second and if you have music on it
and its original music you pay more so I
got material from CNN I got material
from CBS ABC not Fox although i went to
fox i got material from television
stations in Puerto Rico I mean I got
footage from everywhere and i paid over
fifteen thousand dollars just in
archival footage and i was so sparing
with that archival footage so it's
really expensive to use archival footage
fair use i want to talk about fair use
because that's really really really
important i was just in a documentary
real art et al stereotypes which should
be circulating around about Latinos
stereotypes and every single film in
there is they use they did not pay a
penny for it and they used every single
feature film you could ever imagine that
had Puerto Ricans Mexicans Latinos in it
and they use fair use and the first
thing you saw after the title was fair
use you should because it's for
educational purposes is an educational
video so i use the west side story which
would have cost me thousands and
thousands of dollars thousands and
thousands of dollars for that footage
because i had to get not just the rights
from the filmmakers but from the
families of the choreographer the writer
of the music Bernstein I mean and I did
I did try to track them all down and
finally resort it to fair use because I
couldn't track them all down they would
respond to me and I couldn't afford it
anyway and then the way that I got out
of you haven't seen this footage there's
some footage of the 30s where people are
dancing because Tony used to go to the
movies in Puerto Rico and that's how she
knew the United States is through the
movies so I used footage of the 30s and
what I did was I went to this place that
sells trailers so they will sell you the
trailers from these old movies for a
thousand dollars you can use as much of
that trailer as you want the thousands
of so i had to find all these ways in
which you know reduced cost so it's
extremely expensive there was some
footage that I got from a person who
wanted to become a consultant on the
film so a lot of the footage is of the
Bronx but I made it was like New York
everywhere and he wanted to become a
consultant on the film plus he wanted me
to give him a licensing fee and I was
like so then waited a couple of years
and eventually I checked to see if it
was in the public domain and because it
was made with government money it was in
the public domain so all those years
he's been charging people for licensing
rights when it was in the public domain
because they've been made with
government money so look to the
government for the films that they make
because they're in the public domain and
you don't have to pay for them you may
have to pay for duplication but you
don't have to pay for them so I got some
footage from you know the Congress
Congress and all I had to do was just
you know pay for the transfer I think it
was 35 millimeter to a DVD but you know
I could never afford that footage so
it's extremely expensive even though you
know equipment is lowering costs if you
really want to get to like Public
Television which most of us do because
it's a wider audience the reality is
that it's going to cost you and if you
want to put it up on the net the same
rules prevail so you have to get the
rights from the net so some of this will
not be able to go off on the neck so
don't have the rights for it and in a
couple of years some of the rights will
refer back we revert back to the
companies and so I'm stuck with having
to raise money to get the right again
because I couldn't afford any more than
that so those are the considerations I
think it's really important for you to
think about because the net the internet
now is a place where many more people
want to put stuff on and then put stuff
on and then they have to take it down so
I know that a lot of YouTube's have been
taken down you know I do small videos
and my colleagues were always saying put
up on YouTube and I'm like permission
for this footage so I can't steal
somebody's footage and then put it up
and make believe that it's mine I can't
invest online ethical so I've been
trying to track down people and get
permission from them and then saying
this is a specific way I'm going to use
it it's for this community organizing
and it's for YouTube those are the only
two ways i'm going to use it and then
for the most part people will give me
permission so i just got permission for
coming in brazil for a film on
stop-and-frisk because i'm using pieces
of that and this other DVD I'm doing so
I told her this is who I am here's my
political credentials etc etc giving
your footage for free world volunteers
I'm paying out of pocket for this DVD
and she was like I'm so happy why this
my footage and I thought oh my god she
has to be young she has to be a part of
that indymedia people i know because an
old-timer what's that no honey you got
to pay me
so I did want to say those things about
archival use and sometimes people will
sign releases and say they will be in
your film and they will back out and you
have to take the mat so I had a
situation not with this film where I was
doing a tape called sister song about
women of color in the reproductive
health movement and being ignorant of
many aspects of native culture I asked
the woman who I was going to videotape
if it was okay to shoot portions of the
sweat lodge that she was doing in Oxnard
California and she said I'm going to
speak to the elders and they're gonna
let me know if it's okay for you and
what you can do and so I like based on
what she said I shot what she said I
could shoot and then i showed it because
it was a collaborative and I showed it
to the collaborative and this one woman
I think she was a bad chick and she said
I want nothing to do with this project I
was like what I want nothing to do with
this project you're like Columbus you
raped us I was like what I was like what
what and then she said I can't support
this project than she lobbied and I
thought oh my god what did I do wrong
and so I said you have to tell me what I
did wrong and she said this is a Lakota
tradition and you didn't go to the
Lakota because they told you they would
have told you you can't do this and I
had to take out everything and I did I
told him taken out everything you say I
can't do and we figured out a way to do
whatever we had to do with the sweat
lodge so that we were not we were not
violating and other cultures
prohibitions it was very harmless of
profaning we were doing something that
was profane to them and I was so upset
that she would think that you know be
with my political consciousness that I
would consciously you know want to hurt
somebody else but I had to take it there
was nothing I could do she was right and
I was wrong and so you have to rectify
when you do something wrong even if it
costs you money and so we took it out
and you know the film you're fine the
film works you focused on a young women
and why they want to do a sweat lodge
and you know the piece worked it would
have been more gorgeous if we had the
other material but that material will
never be used so you know I think the
thing is you have to know about this
especially if you're not from another
you know culture you have to know what
the prohibitions are and in some cases
you know the prohibitions are really
very serious in some cases you know you
can negotiate so that's probably the
best thing you can do question so can
you talk you sir you mention other
projects can you talk about I'll being a
pro Rican woman documentarian shapes the
project survive and the second piece is
I've brought a bunch of our students for
their Latin American women's class at
John Jay College they have stories to
tell as well and maybe documentary is a
way to tell their stories what would you
tell them they're just sorry how much on
the go to oral history I would tell me
because it's cheaper and easier to do I
mean it's not easy but you know to take
out a full-fledged documentary like most
people say i wanna now i want to make a
90-minute film and I'm like why
classrooms are 45 50 minutes why would
you make a 90-minute film you're going
to see their pieces make a 30 minute
film and then we can have a conversation
about it so you know knowing your
audience is really important so um I
leave something emotional so I've just
you know really interesting intellect
right I've been around the block many
times but I lead from the emotion and so
one side know what the story is my
selects are always going to be cuz how
does this tell the story does this tell
the story in that it drives things
forward does it tell the story because
it punctuates does it tell the story
because it makes people cry because it
makes them feel human because it makes
them feel something very deep so I feel
like the kinds of media that I make I'm
always looking for people to feel deeply
because I feel like in this society
where nesta sized what desensitize
you'll know what it feels like to feel
some things I don't know what I'm
feeling I know exactly what I'm feeling
I'm angry you know I'm hurt I'm happy
you know I'm enraptured so for me it and
I think you know part of being coming
from a culture that in some cases is in
touch with that in ways that aren't
always helpful and in ways that are
extremely helpful they're extremely you
really informs the work that I do so I
want to capture the essence of a person
if I can that's what I want more than
anything else but I also want to make
people feel and even if it means that it
hurts so if you know you have to
remember something that hurts that's
okay so when I first started showing the
film a lot of the people from the older
generation who never been asked what was
it like growing up at a time of rabid
racism against border Ricans in New York
they've never been asked I mean people
would get up in screenings and like
start like yelling and you don't like
and I would be like they're venting they
never asked and here's an opportunity
for them to say what happened to them so
for instance there's a story in here
about Alice cardona going with her
mother she's a little girl knocking on a
door and the woman says are you she says
the motor sister the little to Alice did
I say how do apartamento thanks Peter
Gunn an apartment and the woman says are
you Puerto Rican and the mother says yes
and she says we don't rent to Puerto
Ricans and she slams the door in her
face that kicked up so much stuff for
people in audiences that kicks up an
enormous amount Julio talks about being
beat up because he's a spic that brings
up stuff a lot of people react to digna
being slapped because a lot of people
were slapped so I went I'd learned how
to speak English when I was four years
old on the Spanish dominant I had a
traumatic experience in learning how to
speak English but I learned it fast and
I remember there were Cuban young girls
who came I went to Catholic school where
they torture you and
and so these Cuban young women didn't
speak English and I remember one who got
up and she said to me I have to go to
the bathroom and so I said to her say I
have to go to the bathroom and she was
like I can't she was like this oh boy oh
boy at home Deanna by eight that you
tell the teacher tell the teacher and I
was like she has to go to the bathroom
and the nun would said she has to say
and then I would say but she has to go
look she's gonna do it on herself she
said she has to say and the girl starts
crying and I'm like and she peed on
herself defeat her so she was mortified
and then one of the nun do she told her
she was a filthy Pig and she had to
leave the room so if you never asked
those are your experiences right over
and over no it's not just one time well
then you know final and when you see
somebody expressing it it's like I want
to say it so that's going to be the
reality for the oral histories that you
do sometimes people will be asked for
the first time what was your experience
remember a lot of people you I did this
whole thing about from the margins to
the center we were always on the margins
so what does it like to be in the center
where all of a sudden people are looking
at you and they're asking you and
everything that you say people get
overwhelmed with the newness of the
tally and you have to be prepared for
that telling oh I would say go to oral
history first because it's cheaper it's
easier and easier you know because this
takes it's an elaborate thing took me
six seven years to do this film but
that's good you know I was no crazy in
the middle of it because I story 2001 so
I would say ask them to do the oral
histories and to do the oral histories
of the people in their community that
they respect and love because nobody's
going to capture that information so it
doesn't matter what community you come
from you want to capture those people in
that community that means something to
you so I always said go to your mother
or your grandparents nobody's ever asked
that you know I took my mother to to
City College when I was a student there
we live right across the street from
City College she'd never been inside
night open mic on with me and she said I
can't go
I'm nothing these are students learning
people like full of come out she
went with it she didn't want to go I
won't find another body she did the same
thing nobody ever asked her I asked her
so you know your people who nobody ever
asked them and then you finally asked
them oh my god you know it's you know I
said before that when people do oral
histories they change before your eyes
they become young again they become
those people that used to be and it's a
pleasure to watch them it's a pleasure
you know they're like when they remember
it's fabulous I mean there's nothing
better honestly you know I used to do
films before I'd oral histories and I
would put the monitor right in the old
days of old fashioned video we put the
monitor and I would stand behind the
monitor to watch the women watching
themselves because that was the pleasure
for me that they would see themselves
they were on the screen who they really
were you know they were fighting for
their rights and they were on the screen
there's no greater for me there's no
greater pleasure than that so um you
know tell them to do oral histories
because you know those stories can be so
extraordinary and you know they'll never
be captured unless your students
captured so everything
I'm going elsword I was wondering if it
was easier for her to actually a ground
almost support and all and to actually
do this during the time of the
revolution people supposed to me let's
say I wanted to focus on the Dominican
later away of like immigrants and how
they came to let the Washington idea
where the Puerto Ricans inside one but
like something that kind of bothering me
now is that Washington Heights being my
friend identified changing and our
culture not being there communicate like
and the many things like not having
their culture there you are not having a
place to like go when they come from
yard whether legal or illegal so I don't
see any support like let's say I wanted
to start programs for like kids or
whatever but tutoring programs i don't
see in middle school
see sports teams of tutoring clubs I
don't see anything neighborhood was just
wondering because atomic resolution
people had even though there were so
many other things interesting I mean
it's interesting that you think that
that time was a time of resolution so
you know twenty said are organizing in
the 50s and it was not a time of
revolution it was a time of civil rights
but civil rights remember was not in the
mainstream it became mainstream much
later on it was always peripheral and
the most radical elements within the
civil rights movement stayed marginal so
you know the push in any society is that
anything that is radical out of this out
of them out of the center and on the
margins get squeezed into the middle and
homogenized so I think it's important to
remember that so we're in this moment of
incredible pressure to homogenize things
right so we're at a height of
consumerism that didn't exist in the 50s
right that was the beginnings of this
consumerist movement so there were
movements all over the world there were
independence d colonialization movements
all over the world you know movie in
1959 I think it comes independent 59 for
Cuba 61 for some other country the convo
I mean I'm just thinking about like all
these national Wars of liberation that
were happening around the world and
people in the united states including
the civil rights movement on looking out
and seeing all of this happening but the
united states was in an extremely
conservative mode extremely traditional
except for the pockets of resistance so
i think it's really important to
understand that tony started organizing
at a time when there was very little
philanthropic support for not-for-profit
very little not-for-profits period and
so she went to the foundations and you
know a few that would support her that's
how she started these organizations
there were minuscule budgets and people
were working 70 hours for like
pennies I don't think that it was
necessarily easier I think there was a
sense of mission and a sense of need and
urgency that just kept group of people
moving forward you know even if it was
really hard I think later on you know
you have people who are in this cohort
of what we would call the Reformers
right Toni and her group who ultimately
turned out to be revolutionary that's
what's so interesting and then you have
the second way the people she trained in
some cases who are the radicals and then
the radicals you know we're looking for
support how to do it and then you have
movements dissipating and then you have
I think the beginnings of movements so
you know the Wall Street folks are the
beginnings i would say that there in
cooing you know they're not yet fully
gelled there's a lack of an ideology we
were guided by monsters principles the
majority of us were guided by marxist
ideology so we had an ideology to work
with there are multiple ideologies now
and they were very confusing social
movements have been debunked in some
ways and in many ways they've been
disparaged like you didn't do anything
what did you do you didn't do anything
the reality is that the majority of
people in this room would be here if it
hadn't been for all over social
movements so you know we have to think
about the fact that we're in a really
different time so you start small to
build big that's what you have to do you
have to start small you work with people
who have similar interests and then you
start to build from there and you create
these little pockets I want to say that
even though gentrification may be
happening never underestimate people's
resistance to the decimation of their
culture and I think we look to the
Native Americans for that survival
everything else is going to be gone but
we're going to survive and we're going
to hold on to it
so I think there are pockets of extreme
pockets and um washington heights of
dominican culture absolutely it's being
manifested every single day when people
visit each other that's Dominican
culture happening right then in there so
I think we have to think about the ways
that we define culture and we define
resistance because resistance is
incredibly complicated and people have
an infinite array of resources that they
utilize when they want to resist and it
can be passive-aggressive and it's not
usually confrontational but there's
resistance going on and we need to be
able to look and see where that
resistance is happening and then work in
those pockets of resistance so it's like
we have to look for the nuances we have
to be not looking for the big explosions
because I'm going to happen look for the
smaller ones and then work within that
you know and see that it's a lifelong
task and that you need to take breaks
from it you know when I was in the
movement we burned ourselves out it was
seven days a week you know was
relentless it was we got sick we're
gonna have my to take care of ourselves
so we have to replenish I think the
other thing I would say is that if
you're going to be involved in any kind
of social organizing political
organizing I think you have to take care
of yourself and for women that's really
important because women don't normally
they're taking care of everybody else so
I think self-healing is really important
and being in touch with the healing
processes and other people is really
important and encouraging men to take
care of themselves and to heal
themselves because we have the outlet of
crime because we're emotional right as
women we have the outlet that you know
people don't expect us to be strong and
stoic and hold down everything we're
supposed to be sensitive where the
nurturers but men are not allowed to do
that right so what happens when you're a
hypersensitive man and you can't express
that you become the brute you'll become
the abuser but if we encourage men to
tap into who they really are and we
don't shame them you know we're doing
them we're doing ourselves a service
really because it's about being as human
as we possibly can and we have to keep
that in mind so I say organize organize
organize and whatever way possible I
work now for I want to say this because
you know i'm not in the media the way
that i used to be i was in the media
twenty-four-seven not in the media 24-7
anymore I couldn't do it all right
what's getting old I needed a 403b
consistent salary so I took a job at a
Medicaid managed care health plan but
all of the things that I learned
throughout all those years of organizing
and all those years of healing circles
I'm now utilizing in the place that I
work and so I really struggle to create
participatory democracy in a hierarchy
that's what that's what I have to do
right I'm not in a social movement right
now but I have all these ideas and so I
talk about popular education I make sure
that when we do educational work we do
it in utilizing popular education that
we all continue to use the banking
method of education you're an empty
vessel and the experts are going to fill
you up right so popular education says
you have all these survival skills among
these strategies you have all this
knowledge if you came from another
you cross five borders you've got
survival skills of the Union lets you
work with those survival skills let's
translate those into another arena so
never underestimate you know what people
bring to the table because what they
bring to the table is a resilience that
many of us would never ever be able to
match so you want to look for that kind
of thing I mean it's about manifesting I
guess manifesting your humanity in every
single possible way with whoever you can
person thank you very much
you